welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us
for our presentation titled optimizing
cell
viability for single cell omics it's my
pleasure to introduce you to priya harry
post doctoral genomics research fellow
at sativa
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top
of your screen if you have any questions
that arise during the presentation we
encourage you to submit them in the q
a box our speaker will address those
questions
following the end of the presentation
and as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top
right hand corner of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
those credits without further ado please
join me now in welcoming our presenter
priya hari i will now turn the
presentation
over to her welcome
so thank you susie for that kind
introduction yes um my name is priya and
i've been working with saitiva for
over a year now and recently we have
been working
towards optimizing cell viability
for your single cell omics experiments
more specifically we're
talking about the disassociation of
solid tissue samples
for multiple purposes such as
single cell proteomics genomics
transcriptomics
or even for flow cytometry and fact
sorting the
applications are multiple
but first i'd like to begin with this
unfortunately quite corporate looking
slide
but the reason i've chosen this slide to
talk to you with today
is because it shows how the trends of
single cell sequencing
particular genomic sequencing have been
increasing rapidly
in the recent years and is set to
increase much further over the next five
years
but this all began in 2009 with
the first single cell experiment being
conducted
on a four cell stage blastomere of the
mouse
since then in 2014 the first
commercially available
platform for single cell sequencing hit
the market
and now many
of us researchers are able to conduct
research
on a single cell level moving on from
that bulk sequencing we used to do of
all the cells
and being able to look at different
tissue
types and different cell types within
those tissues
and what's particularly important here
is you can see
the vast cost involved in doing these
experiments
particularly the single cell sequencing
experiment itself is
um very costly and the whole process
from cell isolation
to bioinformatic analysis can take up to
two months if not longer now imagine if
at the two month stage you go back and
you realize that your results don't
just quite add up and you begin to
question whether this was because of the
very quality of that input sample
right at the beginning of the process
and in order to bring more confidence to
our results ensure that
our sample is going into the single cell
sequencing
instrument as best and as an optimal
quality
as you can possibly have we'd like to
bring our focus onto this very beginning
stages of the experimentation
so today my talk is going to be focused
on
disassociation and single cell
sequencing from
tissue samples of course single cell
sequencing
and other studies of the like can be
done
on cells in suspension cells grown in
monolayer
or blood samples but these typically
come
in single cells themselves are quite
easy to disassociate off the plate
whereas when we're talking about solid
tissue samples
these samples um these cells
are linked together intrinsically with
signaling mechanisms
throughout the cells adjoining each
other and we want to
without disrupting these too much
maintain
as much information as possible from
that sample
as if that tissue was still within
the organism the patient that you begin
with
and by doing this when we come on to
doing the rna and dna extraction the
purification and the single cell
sequencing experiments
we hopefully be able to gain all the
information we need
for much interesting um things that
we would not have found by doing bulk
sequencing such as identifying the
therapy resistant subpopulations
or understanding the tumor heterogeneity
or looking at how metamostasis has
happened
and in order to address these important
questions
it is important for us to
have a very standardized procedure for
tissue disassociation
this slide here is a quote that
summarizes what i've just been saying
but at sativa we want to be able to
provide
you researchers whether you're academics
a biofarmer
or industry-leading medical companies
in ensuring that your input the sample
the very
the most important part of your
experiment goes
in to the single cell sequencing at the
most
um confident standards
to begin this journey we started by
interviewing and talking to many
researchers who are currently doing
tissue disaggregation for single cell
experiments and we particularly talked
to them about the challenges that
they're facing with this
first of all at the top and what was
highlighted by almost everyone we spoke
to was that the whole process took a
very long time
now not only is this a problem because
we're very busy individuals and this is
not the only thing that we might be
doing during our day
and it might cut into our coffee breaks
but it's important because many of our
researchers are dependent upon
patient samples and experiments that
could happen
in the evening or in the small hours of
the day
it's also important um because
if a process takes a long time the
longer that sample is
out of the organism out of the patient
the more and more
that tissue sample is being exposed to
different stresses
that can alter the way that cell has
behaved
before it enters our single cell
sequencing equipment and machinery
thereby possibly in altering our
interpretation of the results
and this is something that we need to
try to minimize
and avoid as much as possible
the fact that it takes a long time leads
into the second biggest problem that we
heard
time and time again was low viability
the lower the viability the
more and more dead cells we fought which
are not very useful to us at all but
these are not the cells that we want to
sequence
in fact most single cell sequencing
technologies
recommend that your sample be at least
75
viable the lower the viability
of the sample the more cleanup processes
you're going to have to do with your
cells
meaning that the whole process takes a
lot longer
again going back to issue number one
the third problem i've got on here is
sample size and availability
now particularly during this pandemic
time
although these this research we did
was conducted prior to the pandemic
sample availability was already an issue
this is dwindled more and more as we
speak
sample sizes are reducing as well
because
in a good way technologies now enable
surgeons and nurses and those involved
to take smaller and smaller biopsies
from our patients
in order to minimize their discomfort
but that means that by the time the
pathologist has looked at the samples
and they're available to the researcher
they've got very little material to work
with and then if of that very little
material the viability is low
you've got even less to work with
therefore it's incredibly important
that from that small tissue sample that
is incredibly precious have we
even managed to get hold of it that we
get the best information that we can
from that sample
in the bottom corner here i've already
iterated cell stress and transcription
changes
because this goes hand-in-hand with
everything
all the other challenges on here
and finally the last two on my slide
here
are poor reproducibility and automation
which again go hand in hand
the current processes are not automated
which means they are very user dependent
and we all know but between myself and
my colleagues no matter how hard we try
there will be inherent variability
and the more variability we introduce
into our results
the more we will end up doubting the
final results and
trying to decipher what is true and what
is not true
so these are the challenges that are
currently being faced with tissue
disassociation
and they really stem from
the workflow in which tissue
disassociation is typically conducted
so i've put together here a summary of
the typical manual disaggregation
process
the first of all the experiments begin
by taking your piece of tissue and the
most basic of equipment
a pair of scalpels or scissors and
tweezers
and you are to mince the tissue to as
fine as possible
one to two millimeter squared or a grain
of rice they say
as you can see from the image this is
quite easy to conduct
but quite rudimentary it can take about
five to twenty minutes depending on the
size of the tissue the toughness of the
tissue
it could even take longer then we scrape
up those
pieces of tissues and put them into our
enzyme cocktail
depending on the nature of your enzymes
this you may need to incubate your
sample at 37 degrees
or in a cold room or in an ice bucket
this process can take from 30 minutes to
overnight
and depending on whether you have a
rotating mechanism or not
that will constantly rotate the sample
you may have to go in yourself and
periodically shake or trickery
your sample to release the cells often
finally to separate out the remaining
clumps from your cell suspension
you use a cell strainer all of these
processes as you can see are subject to
temperature variations
time variation and user dependent
variabilities
just going to go over these in a little
bit more detail for example
at the first stage when we are cutting
the tissue by cutting into the tissue
rapidly to make them as small as
possible we're effectively slicing
through
many many cells rupturing them rendering
those cells useless for experiments
it is also difficult to regulate the
temperature during mincing quite often
this is conducted
inside a cell cultural tissue culture
hood of which temperature is
purely dependent on what the room
temperature is
and finally before we pick up our
samples and put them
into our tube of enzymes
we are bound to lose some material to
the list as to the dish as we will never
be
able to recover every single bit of that
sample
variability like i said is also caused
by
different procedures and different
people for instance i may find that
chopping the tissue slowly but gently is
better
yet a colleague of mine may say let's do
it as fast as possible
but they might be operating much harder
either way what
how are we to know which is the best
procedure and
how much impact these cells are having
not on
not just visually on your sample but
right down to the genomic level
finally i'd like to mention how we
noticed in that filter above
there's a lot of sample that was
remaining in the cell strainer
after the complete disassociation
process
that again is a subset of sample that we
will never
analyze or get the meaningful data from
we could choose to digest that even more
but chances are then that sample has
been stressed so much that how can we be
sure
that what we're seeing there is not an
artifact of the stress caused by the
amount of digestion put forward on that
sample
so in order to address these challenges
and questions
sativa have been working on a solution
in order to
optimize the cell viabilities and yields
and to be able to preserve that
transcriptome
and reflect the original state of that
tissue
we want to be able to take into
consideration
the variation in tissue composition
which is important for single cell
sequencing
maybe even incorporate the extracellular
matrix and look at heterogeneity in the
protocol
and finally hopefully detect those rare
cells which we're unable to do by bulk
sequencing
so due to restrictions that are
currently imposed it means that until
this product is fully launched
unfortunately i can't show you the
product nor can i give you the name of
the product
but i really hope to be able to do so in
the future
in the meantime however i'm going to try
to describe the product to you
to the best that i am allowed to do so
in the case of sativa's new solution we
will be placing the tissue
in a single-use disposable bag format
in this format the tissue will never get
be in contact with any mechanical
or sharp parts of the instrument
in fact the the tissue which you do not
need to mince
will be placed into the disassociation
chamber
which can be controlled to a temperature
of your desire
the mechanism will act upon your tissue
and little as five to ten minutes your
sample could be fully disassociated
and ready for further processing
downstream
so to put this into a little bit more
context this process is
gentle due to the lack of any sharp
edges
or anything touching the tissue and it
is also
quick meaning that cell viability and
yield are much
improved and i don't need to take my
word for it as in the coming few slides
i'll be showing you some of the data
the instrument is programmable and you
can
set the temperature anywhere between 0
degrees
and 40 degrees celsius meaning that
you are free to optimize this and choose
the temperature
best suited to your enzymes needs
you are able to put in the enzyme
cocktail of your choice
meaning that that will be one less
variable that
you as a researcher need to consider and
you can choose the enzyme cocktail that
you know to be perfect
for your tissue sample already the
limited amount of materials
and equipment that we have in this
process by eliminating things such as
disused
silver scissors scalpels we
are not likely to lose material
moreover and again i will go on to show
you
that with our system we have a complete
cell suspension
there's very little remaining on that
cell strainer
when you finish the process the fact
that this is
automated means that we can avoid user
variability
as day by day no matter who uses the
system
the output should be the same
provided that the sample is the same of
course if the sample has variability
in itself there's very little that we
can do
but most importantly this procedure
is rapid it is much quicker than the
current methods that i've described
as even in 30 minutes we're able to
disassociate
very tough tissues such as the mouse
lung tissue
so now as i've promised i'll go on to
show you some of that performance data
here i'm comparing tissues disassociated
using our automated system
versus the manual disaggregation that i
described a couple of slides earlier
first and foremost the table on your
left shows the
average sampled incubation times at 37
degrees celsius
this is to say that with our automated
samples
this is the time taken for the full
full tissue disaggregation as i
mentioned earlier
you can put in the whole sample no need
for pre-mincing
into the disassociator and this is the
length of time that we have optimized
for the full disassociation of the
given samples here the mouse lung kidney
liver and spleen
however with the manual i've only
recorded here the one constant
the time that we leave it in the
incubator for however the length of time
that it might have taken for the
preparation of these samples the manual
mincing of these samples into the small
grains
is of course variable and an additional
time that you need to add
onto the time indicated here all of
which of course are already longer
than the time taken for the automated
processing
next following tissue disaggregation
you can pass the cells through the cell
strainer to remove the
cell clumps however as you can see from
the automated disaggregation
from the lung kidney liver and spleen
very little if
any solid bits of tissue are left in the
strainer
meaning that a hundred percent of that
sample has flown through
and will be available for your analysis
however with the manual processing you
can see
much of that tissue still remains
meaning that those samples will
or that tissue will not be available for
analysis later in the in your process
following the tissue disaggregation and
cell straining
the cells will be centrifuged and the
red blood cell lysis
step continues continued on
following which we use an automated cell
counter
in order to count the cells and assess
the cell viability
what you can see instantly is of all
four tissues that we have
been working on that viability is higher
in fact in the case of the mouse lung 50
percent higher than the
manual processes that are currently
being used and in all cases you can see
how good
the variability is between
the samples processed with the automated
compared to the manual process
by having over 75 viability
or cases hundred percent of times would
remove the need for post-processing like
the removal of dead cells and there
would also of course be less debris in
these samples
reducing the potential of logging
blocking the fluidic channels of the
single cell sequencing
machinery following on from cell
viability
we're able to count the cells i've
represented the cell yields
by counting the number of viable cells
per milligram
of input tissue to ensure that all
experiments are equally comparable
you can see again that in all cases of
tissues
we have much higher yields of
cells remaining following the automated
disassociation compared to the manual
disassociation
in fact tens to hundreds of thousands
more cells
per milligram can be analyzed with our
system
this is fantastic particularly if you're
wanting to look for those rare cells
and achieve the concentrations required
for your single cell sequencing
experiments
meaning that you can be sure or you are
more likely to find
information that has not been discovered
before
finally i'd like to draw your attention
to a
different experiments here showing how
well
we can disassociate tissues that are
small in size typical biopsy size
tissues
as little as 25 milligrams to large
pieces of tissue
such as a one gram of mouse liver
or one whole kidney bearing in mind that
none of these tissues have been
pre-minced
you can see here that the viabilities of
these samples remain incredibly high
despite the size of the tissue and we
also have very comparable yields
despite the size of the tissue
this is fantastic in giving us
confidence that we are not losing any
material
and that we are successfully able to
disassociate
even when sample availability might be
compromised but
reasons beyond our control
so by way of summary i've brought us
back to this slide of challenges
but the automated solution that sativa
proposed and are hoping to launch in the
near future
is addressing the fact that the current
procedure
takes a long time we've our new solution
is actually much quicker allowing you to
just disassociate tissues
in less than five minutes
we've also addressed low viability as
you seen from my data
viabilities much improved from our
process often hitting
close to 100 viable cells and we've also
been able to disassociate
very small pieces of tissue just as
successfully
as larger pieces of tissue the fact that
we are able to do this in a more gentle
manner
in a quicker manner means that we were
already
quite confident that cell stress and
transcriptome changes can be minimized
but in order to look into this in a
little bit more detail
we are currently working on analyzing
the single cell profile of these cells
and we hope to be able to share that
data with you very soon
finally by introducing automation to the
tissue desegregation process
we are able to reduce variability
and the poor reproducity problems that
have been faced so far
allowing for more streamlined
experiments in the future
so that's all the data i have to share
with you today
but if you would like more information
on how to optimize your single cell
experiments
this is this white paper here i think
will be very useful for those
particularly starting out in the field
of single cell sequencing
it has a lots of nice information on
different methods
different workflows and how this might
impact you
in the future
so that's it for me thank you for
listening to my talk
i do hope you found it useful you now
have the opportunity to ask me some
questions
and if your answer question does not get
addressed today
please do email me at the contact
details given on the slide before and
i'll be happy to help you
thank you very much
thank you priya for that outstanding
presentation and we will now
move into the live q a portion of the
presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
it looks like we have quite a few
questions already coming in priya
our first question is how do you measure
viability
thank you for the question um yes so
we've been
measuring viability following tissue
disassociation
um starting with red blood cell lysis to
ensure that this isn't contaminating our
cell counts
the method we use is by a commercially
available automated cell counter
that counts the cells on the basis of
dappy and acridine orange staining
and that allows us to count not only the
cells but it also does the calculations
for cell viability for us too
we highly recommend using an automated
cell count for
cell counting thank you so much
and have you tested or done any kind of
comparisons
using human tissue
yes unfortunately we at sativa
are unable to work with human samples
ourselves due to
the restrictions however we have been
working with key opinion leaders
at prestigious institutes across the uk
the usa
and across the world who will be or who
are
in fact testing the instrument or
prototypes of them
with human patient samples and we're
very much looking forward to sharing the
results
of these experiments with you soon
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience members for these great
questions
have you disassociated frozen tissue
with the automated process
yes we have um had a try at this i'd
like to point out that the key mission
of this product at the beginning right
now is to focus on fresh tissue
however i can say that i have personally
tried
disassociating a tissue from frozen um
it thaws very quickly and i had
very good viability results given the
circumstances
thank you so much and what about the
nuclei can you extract that
nuclei again this is something that
we've not tested
ourselves as i've mentioned earlier
fresh tissue is currently our focus
but knowing how the mechanism of our
instrument works
we don't see that to be particularly
challenging
the the format of the instrument means
that any sample can be accepted
any buffers can be accepted and this
should gently
also be able to lyse the nuclei as well
it is something that we endeavor to test
though ourselves very soon
thank you so much priya we have time for
a few more questions
an audience member wants to know would
automated tissue
processing reduce the level of debris
and thus reduce the cleanup
steps that are required yes
this is quite likely to happen by
processing the cells gently and avoiding
the use of scissors
and scalpels we're not cutting into the
cells anymore and by not cutting into
the cells but
gently teasing those cells apart you're
less likely to produce debris
you're also less likely to release any
genomic dna that's going to cause those
cells to stick back together again
and thereby this gentle approach does
mean that we would reduce
um sorry we would reduce the
level of debris and any need for
post-processing
thank you so much let's talk about risks
are there any contamination
risks with automated tissue processing
although no um nothing can be purpose
i i mean sorry although nothing um
can be guaranteed what i can tell you is
our system has been designed in a way to
limit contamination
by reducing the amount of equipment you
need for starters
for example there's no incubator there's
no dishes there's no scalpels
we're already reducing contamination
your sample will be secure
in this bag and it doesn't even touch
any of the machinery
of the instrument therefore again
meaning that we have reduced
contamination
and it is a whole closed chamber
therefore we at sativa have taken
as many precautions as possible to
ensure that
contamination does not occur in your
samples
thank you so much brian thank you for
our audience members these great
questions coming in
in which area of research is automated
tissue
processing likely to have the most
positive
impact we believe that this is going to
have the most positive
impact um particularly with groups or
institutes who are processing
a large number of samples the fact that
we can process these samples quickly
means that you're more able to get on
with
the rest of the important parts of the
experiments
and generating that data we also
anticipate that this would be
in the single cell ohmic space the
proteomics the genomics the
transcriptomics
or particularly coming from clinicians
or patient samples
we envision that this instrument would
be very beneficial
thank you so much priya an audience
member says even with automated tissue
processing the cell availability is
still variable depending on the type
and sample type is there anything
further that can be done to improve the
viability with kidney for example
yes it's true i mean if you did look at
my slides closely i can see that you
noticed
that with the first um kidney samples
the viability was
just around the 75 mark but then if you
remember the slides that i showed you
much later on with the smaller size
samples
um the viabilities had improved at that
time more nearing the 80 to 90 percent
mark
and i know this myself because i've been
working on these experiments but that
was due to some optimization that we did
in in the interim of between those
experiments where
i change some of the settings um which
you can't which that you will be free to
do
on the instrument we also played about
with the enzyme mixes
and similarly this is what we hope that
the researchers
would do as well um you're sure you're
very well versed with optimizing things
and you can really use this new
instrument to your advantage
thank you and why is there such
variation
in cell variability due to the sample
type
and size
for that question of course it can
really depend
on a number of factors um
first of all this the origin of the
sample how far has that sample traveled
from the time it was within the
patient body or the mouse body to
receiving the researchers hands it can
also depend on the amount of
surface area to volume ratio you have
with your enzymes
it can depend on you know the the
processing
by um different techniques and
different users but this is what we're
trying to all of these
things we're trying to limit using this
new automated system
thank you so much priya we have time for
a couple more questions
how does the overall process time
compare between the two methodologies
from start
to finish so
first of all from start to finish
the manual process as i showed in my
first slide
can take anywhere from one hour from you
know you do your mincing and then you do
the incubation and you go on to the next
steps
um to because it's an overnight process
it could even take days however with the
automated
um solution so far we can disassociate
the toughest of tissues
without any pre-mincing in as little as
half an hour
therefore the automated process
is a much quicker process from
having a solid tissue down to your
single cell suspension
thank you so much an audience member
wants to know do you obtain a true
single cell suspension or do you observe
doublets
and aggregates yes so
so far um looking at my results from the
cell counter i can see
that at least 80 percent of my
population will be
individual cells it is true that
sometimes we can see
some aggregates forming within these
cells but that's not to say that that's
because of the
process this could be due to the enzymes
it could be
due to the post-processing such as
during the centrifugation stage or the
red blood cell lysis stage
what we are looking to do very soon is
to analyze the cells with flow cytometry
because that will really help us to
distinguish between the single cells and
the doublets
thank you so much now we have time for
one more question have you looked at
sequencing data comparison to check
for transcriptable um integrity
yes so um as i was saying earlier it is
something that we are currently working
on
and i'm hoping to share the details with
you quite soon but i will share with you
that so far the data is really looking
promising
towards supporting the automated system
at reducing stress on the cells
this has been a fantastic presentation
thank you so much for your time today
we're out of time for q a but i want to
remind our audience members that any
questions that were submitted and not
answered today
by our speaker will be addressed via
email
thank you again priya and thank you to
the audience for their outstanding
questions
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months and
please remember to share it with your
colleagues
who might be interested in today's topic
and don't miss out on the other
presentations
on our agenda visit the agenda tab in
the auditorium
for a full listing thank you again priya
and thank you all for your participation
until next time stay safe stay healthy
take care bye